now the UK government may be reluctant
to talk about life beyond the lockdown
right now but others are more willing to
discuss it
Nicola Sturgeon has already laid out
some of her thinking this week and today
the mayor of Greater Manchester wants to
do the same so could speak now to Andy
Burnham thank you for being on the
program just before we get to your plans
if you like for trying to ease the
lockdown and the northwest maybe
emerging as a new hot spot for
coronavirus I know that you've spoken
out before about shortages of protective
equipment in the northwest the
difficulties in getting your hands on it
in Greater Manchester are you ready
certainly still a challenging situation
but the way in which Greater Manchester
and the Northwest has responded has been
magnificent to be honest the Health
Service is coping and there is capacity
in the health service and I've had a
team working to bring in more protective
equipment from around the world actually
so Greater Manchester has got got
supplies now additional to the supplies
coming from the government so it's tough
but you know we are we are working hard
and we're getting through it now Boris
Johnson would be back at work from
tomorrow and of course he's going to
face some pretty career-defining
decisions about how and when to change
the lockdown measures that are currently
in place I know this is something that
you've been thinking about as well
what's your view on how it should be
done well so it's not a call for an
early lifting of the lockdown figures we
saw yesterday are really really
difficult so you know I'm not
necessarily saying that we have to move
forward now what I would say though is
that kist armor is right to call for an
open debate about when and how that's on
that second question how the two main
ideas that have been put forward are a
regional approach to lifting it or a
sectoral approach I see problems with
both of those a region by region
approach would be unworkable in my view
but a sectoral approach will possibly be
unfair on businesses in certain parts of
the economy for instance hospitality
just to say to ours restaurants and
other leisure or entertainment venues
that you you'll be last and
there just really isn't a message that
they can work with so what I'm saying is
let's have a standard sled approach to
this ie permission to open is linked to
businesses ability to operate safe
working standards and social distancing
so that gives everybody a route back to
work but it might mean perhaps that they
have to limit the number of their
employees and work to begin with and I
think that is a better way to approach
the release from lockdown and the other
ideas that have been circulating so far
so just be clear what you're saying is
that for example pubs or restaurants
could open much earlier than most people
are expecting if they can prove that
they can be done in a socially distance
way yeah if you take a standards that
approach you're putting health and
safety at heart of this release from
lock down and that's the way to go in my
in my view and it would be overseen by
the Health and Safety Executive but yes
it would allow businesses in all parts
of the economy to innovate perhaps to
change the way they work limit the
number of employees that they have him
work but at least it would give them a
route back and I'm worried that if we're
going down that the sectoral approach it
could have heavy consequences for a city
like Manchester or say Blackpool in our
town that really depends upon tourism
and hospitality so if the impact of a
sectoral approach could hit certain
places hard so what I'm saying to the
Prime Minister is you know think about a
standards layer approach actually create
a national recovery council because we
all need to have a voice in this debate
but these decisions that you are about
to take are crucial for the economy of
the Northwest of England and we need to
be in the room debating it with you at
the same time now there is risks
attached to this as well aren't they
businesses have got a vested interest in
reopening how would you check that
they're continuing to follow the
guidelines well I would have this
overseen by the Health and Safety
Executive so you know if people are
making complaints that procedures aren't
being followed that there can be an
investigation and people can be required
to close again we saw that when we went
into lockdown a lot of confusion and
actually some breaching of the standards
so we don't want to see that again we
need to put safety at the heart of this
but then
overseen by the health and safety it's
active working with public health
England but beyond the safety Sophie as
well we need to start thinking about
building a better economy building back
better so one of the other ideas I would
put forward today is the ongoing
government support for businesses should
be linked to good employment standards
and particularly payment of the real
living wage you know we have many of us
have been at home while other people
have been out there running the country
in supermarkets and care homes and other
places warehouses and they are the
lowest paid people in society and I
don't feel at all comfortable with that
and I think coming from this we should
say ongoing government support or
businesses should be linked to good
employment and very specifically payment
of the real living wage I believe in
this computer last 20 years we've been
overpaying people at the top of
organizations and under paying people at
the bottom and I think we need a real
national commitment to build back better
and recognize that those minimum wage
heroes who've been out there working for
us all need a much better deal than the
one they've had in recent years now the
briefings that we've some journalist
have been getting about the state of
mind of Boris Johnson is that he appears
to be someone who's big priority is
keeping the infection levels low
avoiding a second peak I was interested
to hear you talking there about you know
some of the industries around Manchester
or Blackpool do you think the government
is right to be so cautious yes I think
the government is right to be very
cautious because you know the worst of
all worlds would be an early release on
managed release that then saw the virus
spreading again in parts of the country
I don't think the government can could
or should take any risks in that
direction so I think the premise that is
right to have cautious instincts as is
the health secretary but let's use this
time to debate properly and agree how we
are going to move from the position that
we're in at the moment I think Kirsten
is right to say the public need a sense
of that because otherwise people are
losing hope and they can't can't see
where where we're going they need to see
that light at the end of the tunnel even
if it is some time away we should be
honest with people
about how we're going to move forward at
the same time do you have any concerns
that if the government does start
spelling out more detail about how it
could ease the lockdown it may mean that
people effectively don't adhere to the
proposals there is a risk of that but I
would say if they answer that question a
bit more fully about when this would
happen then at least people will be able
to say okay well nothing is going to
change for so long so at least we have
to get back down that to observing the
rules they have a sense of you know it
changed at a certain point I can create
more discipline around the whole process
to be honest
Sophie so we do need to start answering
some of these questions now we do need
to get people ready but living in a very
different way for instance I'm planning
to have social distancing on public
transport so your things aren't going to
be the same we need to be honest with
the public about all of that but I think
the time is now to start having those
debates and even if there's a day
sometime in May or June when measures
will be will be eased at least people
will know and they can start to plan for
that and just finally and your health
secretary in 2009 and in 2010 a time
when a pandemic was right at the top at
the government's risk register and yet
it looks as if the advice and their
plans are in place at the time which
remained in place right up until
coronavirus hit didn't involve a
lockdown or widespread social distancing
a 2011 document said it would not be
possible to stop the spread of a virus
have we been unprepared for this kind of
event for quite a long time well you're
right I mean there was a lot of work on
pandemic planning in the government that
I was in and we dealt with one swine flu
and the official inquiry into that said
it was highly satisfactory I think we're
going to see in time and inquiry into
this one say that things couldn't should
have been done better and I've been
quite supportive of some of the way
their health secretaries handled things
but I think his predecessor the former
health secretary has some questions to
answer because I don't believe the
parties that were put in place where
were as robots that they needed to be
but those questions are for another day
and you know it's not for now there now
is to get through there
get a country on a path that it means
the poor and B of all businesses in the
economy a chance to become back let's
come back better let's come back with
higher standards for our workers
recognizing what they've been doing for
us in these recent times okay Andy
Burnham thank you very much for being on
the program and spending out some of
your ideas much appreciate it thank you